Isaac Stern the famous violinist said
music is what happens between the notes
well well trust is what's built between
the meetings
you know it's the conversation walking
into the conference room it's the
continued conversation when you walk out
of the conference room it's the stopping
somebody in the hallway and be like oh I
meant to tell you
or you know knocking on someone's door
and saying you want to grab lunch you
want to grab a coffee and all of these
seemingly innocuous little things no one
of them does it but over the course of
time relationships and trusts start to
build the problem within a with a
virtual environment is we don't have
between the meetings we just have the
meetings there is no before and after
there is no knocking on someone's door
there's no spontaneity and so what we
have to do is create those things
artificially we actually have to force
those interactions to happen so one of
the things we do on our team is we do a
Monday morning huddle huddle
um is a little bit of time for people to
talk about what's on your uh heart and
mind
um and then we answer some either funny
or poignant question that the Huddle
leader poses
um there is no discussion of work zero
and so we spend 45 minutes to an hour on
the phone with a team and there is no
discussion of numbers or projects or
responsibilities nothing it's just an
opportunity for the team to come
together and start to see each other as
people you know they talk about what
they did with their kids I didn't even
know they had kids you know you start to
learn about who they are so I think you
know you have to force those things one
of the things we've always we've also
seen uh uh uh success with is people um
turning their computers on turning on
Zoom together and just working they
don't have to work together just to have
a face there where in the corner of the
screen where you're working or having
lunch together or having a coffee
together so you have to artificially
create these things it's not great I
mean in in person is always better but
it actually can work it actually it
actually does does create elements of
humanity and trust that you need to
build virtually